en el vídeo pasado empezamos a hacer el
análisis de este circuito y encontramos
que en él se cumplen estas cuatro
ecuaciones que nos van a ayudar a
encontrar todos los voltajes y
corrientes del circuito así es que
tenemos aquí cuatro ecuaciones
simultáneas y cuatro incógnitas y vamos
a resolver este sistema de ecuaciones lo
primero que vamos a hacer es volver a
escribir algunas de estas ecuaciones
pero de una forma más organizada podemos
empezar con esta ecuación de aquí que
salió de la ley de voltajes de kirchhoff
nosotros conocemos cuánto vale bs y aquí
tenemos estas dos incógnitas esta
ecuación de aquí la podemos volver a
escribir como b1 b2 es igual a de s y
esta ecuación de aquí de las corrientes
la podemos escribir como y uno menos
y dos igual a y ese y aquí es un momento
en el que tengo que escoger si quiero
primero resolver las corrientes o los
voltajes porque tenemos estas dos
ecuaciones por acá que relacionan a los
voltajes con las corrientes y lo que
vamos a hacer es sustituir a los
voltajes por a lo que son equivalentes
en términos de las corrientes y entonces
vamos a tener puras ecuaciones en
términos de las corrientes y así es como
vamos a resolver el sistema de
ecuaciones así es que empezamos en esta
ecuación sustituyendo v 1 x y 1 r 1
tenemos y 1 r 1 más de 2 que la
sustituimos por y 2 r2 y 2 r2
y sabemos que eso es igual a bs igual a
de s la segunda ecuación se queda igual
y uno menos y dos es igual a y ese y el
siguiente paso para resolver este
sistema de ecuaciones es encontrar una
forma de eliminar alguna de las dos
corrientes y bueno pues yo voy a escoger
eliminar a la corriente y dos y para
hacer eso lo único que tengo que hacer
es multiplicar a toda la ecuación por r
2 x r 2 y entonces cuando sume estas dos
ecuaciones estos dos términos se van a
cancelar pero vamos a necesitar más
espacio entonces lo escribimos por aquí
primero tenemos esta ecuación de aquí r
uno por uno más
r 2 por y 2 es igual a bs
estas son la misma ecuación simplemente
puse los coeficientes al principio y
luego ponemos por aquí la ecuación de
abajo
r2 x
1 - r 2 por 2 es igual a r 2 por s
vamos a sumar estas dos ecuaciones
podemos ver que estos dos términos se
cancelan nos quedan estos dos términos
sumándose pero tiene la misma variable
entonces podemos factorizar y nos queda
como r1 y r2
y uno que es igual a bs veces más
r2 por y ese y entonces como ya
conocemos todas estas constantes podemos
encontrar y uno claro en términos de
estas constantes así es que y 1 es igual
a bs más r 2 por iese entre r uno más r
2 y ahora lo que quiero hacer es poner
los verdaderos valores de todas estas
constantes y así encontrar el valor de
la corriente y 1 entonces nos vamos a
hacer para abajo y vamos a continuar y
otra vez vamos a hacer un pequeño dibujo
de como teníamos al circuito por aquí
teníamos una fuente de voltaje de 15
volts luego teníamos un resistor con una
resistencia de 4000
este es r 1 luego teníamos otro resistor
por acá pero éste era un resistor de
por aquí se cerraba este lazo pero luego
por aquí teníamos una fuente de
corriente en esta dirección y esa fuente
de corriente tenía 3000 amperes de
intensidad y queríamos encontrar esta
corriente y 1 y esta otra corriente y
dos las dos corrientes que no conocemos
por aquí ya casi encontramos ahí uno
simplemente tenemos que sustituir todos
estos valores aquí y uno es igual a bs
pero bs son 15 volts 15 volts más r 2
por iese r 2 son 2000 oms 2000 oms y
luego y ese son 3000 jan pérez
3000 campers y luego todo esto lo
estamos dividiendo entre la suma de las
resistencias r 1 son 4000 oms 4000 oms y
r2 son 2000 oms entonces y uno es igual
a 15 volts 15 volts
2 kilos oms o 2000 oms por tres mil
jumper es esto se combina para formar 6
volts porque aquí tenemos un por 1000 y
cuando tenemos milián pérez estamos
dividiendo entre 1000 entonces eso se
cancela y homs por amperes nos dan volts
entonces nos quedan 6 volts entre 4000
oms más 2000 oms son 6.000 oms
entonces nos queda 15 621 volts entre
6000 oms y esto es igual 21 entre 6 es
3.5 y bolsa entre oms son amperes pero
aquí también estamos dividiendo entre
1000 entonces son mili amperes así es
que esta corriente de aquí y 1
acabamos de calcular que son 3
puntos 5000 y amperes ya tenemos una de
nuestras incógnitas y con ella podemos
calcular la otra porque por aquí tenemos
esta otra ecuación que nos dice que
menos y dos menos y dos es igual a y s&s
menos y uno menos y uno entonces menos y
dos es igual a y es que son 3.000
amperes 3.000 amperes menos y 1 pero uno
acabamos de calcular que son 3.5 milán
pérez y 3.5 mil amperes
y esto nos queda igual a menos 2.5 mili
amper si eso es menos y 2 ahora podemos
deshacernos de los signos negativos y
entonces ya tenemos que 2 es igual a
punto 5000 y pampers ok
esta es la corriente de aquí bueno ya
podemos empezar a ponerle cuadrados
alrededor de nuestros resultados las
incógnitas que ya conocemos aquí ya
tenemos los valores de todas las
corrientes y ahora lo que nos falta es
encontrar los voltajes por ahora aquí
podemos utilizar la ley de ohm para
encontrar el voltaje a lo largo de este
resistor y este es el voltaje b1 y
sabemos que el voltaje b1 es igual a la
intensidad de la corriente a través del
resistor o sea 1 pero que ya sabemos que
son
punto 5000 amperes
por la resistencia de ese resistor que
son 4000 oms y eso es igual 3.5 por 4
son 14 y tenemos mili amperes y kilo oms
y estos son simplemente volts
así es que ve uno es igual a 14 volts y
ya obtuvimos otro resultado ya conocemos
esta incógnita y la última incógnita es
el voltaje de 2 y lo podemos calcular
con la ley de ohm gay porque es el
voltaje a través de este resistor
entonces b 2 es igual a la intensidad de
la corriente a través del resistor que
es y 2 que ya encontramos que son puntos
5 mil jumper es 0.5 mili amperes
por la resistencia en ese resistor que
son 2000 oms 2 kilos oms y esto nos dice
que b 2 es igual a un volt terminamos
este voltaje de aquí es de un volt y ya
resolvimos el circuito este es un
análisis de circuito completo utilizando
las leyes fundamentales